hi this is the outdoor boys and this is
our Alaskan adventure while we were up
in Alaska one of their favorite things
to do was drive around the four-wheelers
at our family's cabin we had a great
time hanging out picnicking with cousins
and family and it was just absolutely
perfect weather all of this took place
at our family's cabin along the cash
Whitner River in the Susitna Valley
about two hours north of Anchorage soon
as we got there we loaded everybody up
on the four-wheelers and in the trucks
and we drove out to a sandbar on the
Susitna River to have a picnic
in Alaska four-wheelers aren't just for
fun they're an essential tool for
getting around and here is no different
anywhere we wanted to go on the property
we top off the four wheelers whether it
was going fishing or running down to the
river running some errands we take the
four-wheelers Tommie absolutely loved it
he just constantly screamed go fast fast
four-wheelers and he loved it and still
talks about it on this little outing we
went down to a favorite fishing spot
along the river and we got to see a
moose up close where's the moose Tommy
oh look at the moose Tommy